Algorithms in the message passing model,
always assume some topology for
the network.
But suppose you design an algorithm for
one kind of network, and
then run it on another one.
How well will it do?
This lesson considers network topology,
which will give you some techniques for
thinking about this question.
Now in the early days of parallel and
distributed computing,
network topology was a big deal.
Then, through better engineering of
networks and through virtualization,
it seemed like it didn't matter so
much anymore.
That led to cost models,
like the alpha beta or
the latency bandwidth model,
where you could just sweep away a lot of
the details of network
communication under the hood.
But communication layers
are getting faster all the time.
And the scale at which we
operate systems today,
is getting bigger and bigger.
Thus my personal opinion is that once
you have a billion or more processor
systems, the network topology is
going to start to matter again a lot.
And so we shouldn't forget
its basic principles.